This lecture is about the web indexing.
In this lecture we will continue
talking about the web search and we're
going to talk about how to create a web
scale index.
So once we crawled the web, we've got a
lot of web pages.
The next step is to use the indexer
to
Create the inverted index.
In general, we can use the standard
information retrieval techniques for
creating the index, and that is what we
talked about in the previous lecture.
But there are new challenges that we
have to solve for web scale indexing
and the two main challenges.
Our scalability and efficiency.
The index would be so large that it
cannot actually fit in into any single
machine or a single disk, so we have to
store the data on multiple machines.
Also, because the data is so large,
it's beneficial to process the data in
parallel so that we can produce the
index quickly.
Now, to address these challenges,
Google has made a number of
innovations.
One is the Google file system that's a
general distributed file system that
can help programmers manage files
stored on
a cluster of machines.
The second is MapRecuce.
This is a general software framework
for supporting parallel computation.
Hadoop is the most known open source
implementation of map reduce, now used
in many applications.
So this is the architecture of the
Google File System.
It uses very simple centralized
management mechanism to manage it all
the specific locations of files, so
that maintains the file name, space and
look up a table to know where exactly
each file is stored.
The application client would then talk
to this GFS master and then obtain
specific locations of the files that
they want to process.
And once the GFS client obtained
the.
The specific information about the
files, then the application client can
talk to the specific servers where the
data actually sit directly so that you can avoid
involving other nodes in the network.
So when this file system stores the
files on machines the system also
would create a fixed size of chunks
so that data files are separated into
many chunks.
Each chunk is 64 MB, so it's
pretty big, and that's a property for
large data processing.
These chunks are replicated to ensure
reliability, so this is something that
the programmer
doesn't have to worry about.
It's all taken care of by this fire
system, so from the application
perspective, the programmer would see
this as if it's a normal file.
The program doesn't have to know where
exactly it's stored and can just
invoke high level operators to process
the file.
(And)
Another feature is that the data
transfers directly between
application and chunk servers, so it's
efficient in this sense.
On top of the Google File System and
Google also proposed map reduce as a
general framework for parallel
programming.
Now this is very useful to support a
task like a building inverted index.
So this framework is
hiding a lot of low level features from
the program.
As a result, the programmer can make a
minimum effort to create a application
that can be run on large cluster in
parallel.
And so some of the low level details
hidden in the framework, including the
specific network communications or load
balancing or where the tasks are
executed.
All these details are hidden from the
programmer.
There is also a nice feature which is
the built-in fault tolerance.
If one server is broken, let's say
service down and then some tasks may
not be finished, then the map reduce
mechanism would know that the task has
not been done, so automatically
dispatches the task on other servers
that can do the job and therefore again
the program
doesn't have to worry about that.
So here's how MapReduce works.
The input
data will be separated into a number of
key value pairs.
Now, what exactly is in the value will
depend on the data, and it's actually a
fairly general framework to allow you
to just partition the data into
different parts, and each part can be
then processed in parallel.
Each key value pair would be send
to a map function.
The programmer would write map function
of course.
And then the map function would then
process this key value pair and would
generator a number of other key value
pairs.
Of course the new key is usually
different from the old key that's given
to the map as input.
And these key value pairs are the
output of the map function and all the
outputs of all the map functions would
be then collected.
And then there will be for the sorted
based on the key, and the result is
that all the values that are associated
with the same key would be then grouped
together.
So now we've got a pair of a key and a
set of values that are attached to this
key.
So this will then be sent to a Reduce
function.
Now of course, each Reduce function
will handle a different
key, so we will send these output values
to multiple, reduce functions, each
handling unique key.
A reduce function would then process the
input.
Which is a key and a set of values to
produce another set of key values as
the output.
So these output values will be then
collected together to form the final
output.
Right, so this is the general framework
of MapReduce.
Now the programmer only needs to write the
Map function and the Reduce function.
Everything else is actually taken care
of by the MapReduce framework.
So you can see the program really only
needs to do minimum work.
And with such a framework the input data can be
partitioned into multiple parts, each
is processed in parallel, first by map,
and then in the process after we reach
the reduce stage, then multiple reduce
functions can also further process
the different keys and their associated
values in parallel, so it achieves
(some)
It achieves the purpose of parallel
processing of large data set.
So let's take a look at a simple
example and that's what accounting.
How the input is files containing
words.
And the output that we want to generate
is the number of occurrences of
each word, so it's the word account.
We know this kind of counting would be
useful to, for example, assess the
popularity of a word in a large
collection, and this is useful for
achieving effect of IDF weiging.
Or search.
So how can we solve this problem?
One natural thought is that.
This task can be done in parallel by
simply counting different parts of the
file in parallel, and then in the end we
just combine all the counts, and that's
precisely the idea of what we can do
with MapReduce.
We can parallelize on lines in this
input file.
So more specifically, we can assume the
input to each map function is key
value pair that represents the line
number and the stream on that line.
So the first line, for example, has the
key of 1 and the value is "Hello World"
"Bye World"
and just 4 words.
On that line so this key value pair will
be sent to a map function.
The map function would then just count
the words in this line, and in this
case of course there are only four
words.
Each word gets a count of one, and
these are the output that you see here
on this slide.
From this map function.
So the map function is really very
simple if you look at the what the
pseudocode looks like on the right
side you see it simply needs to iterate
over all the words in this line and
then just call the collect function, which
means it would then send the world and
the counter to the collector.
The collector would then try to sort all
these.
key value pairs from different
Map functions, so the function is very
simple and the programmer specifies
this function as a way to process each
part of the data.
Of course, the second line will be
handled by a different map function,
which will produce a similar output.
OK, now the output from the map
functions will be then send to a
collector and the collector will do the
internal grouping or sorting.
So at this stage you can see we have collected
multiple pairs, each pair is a word and
its count in the line.
So once we see all these pairs then we
can sort them based on the key which is
the word.
So we will collect all the counts of
a word like a "Bye" here together.
An similarly we do that
for other words like "Hadoop", "Hello" etc.
So each world now is attached to a
number of values, a number of
counts.
And these counts represent the
occurrences of this word in different
lines.
So now we have got a new pair of a key
and a set of values and this pair will
then be feeding to reduce function.
So the reduce function now would have
to finish the job of counting the total
occurrences of this word.
Now it has already got all these
partial accounts, so all it needs to do
is similarly to add them up so the reduce
function shown here is very simple as well.
You have a counter and then iterate
over all the words that you see
in this array, and then you just
accumulated the count.
And then finally output the key and the
total count, and that's precisely what
we want as the output of this whole
program.
So you can see this is already very
similar to building an inverted index,
and if you think about it, the output
here is indexed by world and we have
already got the dictionary.
Basically we have got the counts, but
what's missing is the document IDs and
the specific
frequency counts of words in those
documents, so we can modify this
slightly to actually build inverted
index in parallel.
So here's one way to do that.
So in this case we can assume the input
to map function is a pair of a key,
which denotes the document ID and the value
denoting the stream for that document.
So it's all the words in that document,
and so the map function will do
something very similar to what we have
seen in the word count example.
It simply groups all the counts of this
word in this document together and it
would then generate the set of key
value pairs.
Each key is a word.
And the value is the count of this
orld in this document, plus the
document ID.
Now you can easily see why we need to
add document ID here.
Of course later in the inverted index
we would like to keep this information
so the map function should keep track
of it and this can be sent to the
reduce function later.
Similarly, another document D2 can be
processed in the same way, so in the
end that again there was a sorting
mechanism that would group them
together and then we will have just
a key like "Java" associated with all the
documents that match this key or the
documents where "Java" occurred.
And the counts.
So the counts of Java in those
documents.
And this will be collected together and
this will be also fed into the reduce
function.
So now you can see the reduce function
has already got input
that looks like a inverted index entry,
right?
So it's just the word and all the
documents that contain the word and
the frequencies of the word in those
documents.
So all it needs to do is simply to
concatenate them
into a continuous chunk of data, and
this can be then written into a file
system.
So basically the reduce function is
going to do very minimum work.
So this is
pseudocode for inverted index
construction.
Here we see two functions.
Procedure Map and procedure Reduce.
And a program with the specify these two
functions to program on top of map
reduce and you can see basically they
are doing what I just described.
In the case of map, it's going to count
the occurrences of word using
associative array and will output the
old accounts together with the document
ID here.
So this is the reduce function
On the other hand, simply concatenates
all the input that it has been given
and then put them together as one
single entry for this key.
So this is a very simple MapReduce
function, yet it would allow us to
construct the inverted index at very
large scale and the data can be
processed
by different machines.
The program doesn't have to take care
of the details.
So this is how we can do parallel index
construction for web search.
So to summarize, web scale indexing
requires some new techniques that go
beyond the standard traditional
indexing techniques, mainly will have
to store the index on multiple
machines, and this is usually done by
using file system like a Google File
System, a distributed file system.
And secondly, it requires creating the
index in parallel because it's so large
it takes a long time to create the index
for all the documents.
So if we can do it in parallel it will
be much faster and this is done by
using the MapReduce framework.
Note that the post the GFS and
MapReduce frameworks are very general
so they can also support many other
applications.